In Unit 1, we talked about the Tropic of Cancer, but I'm not sure if we actually used that word.
The city of Siena where Eratosthenes saw the sun shining vertically down the row
is located on the Tropic of Cancer.
The sun isn't always directly above the Tropic of Cancer
as it happened to be on the summer solstice.
In fact, due to the tilt of the earth, the sun can be directly overhead anywhere between
the Tropic of Cancer, the equator, and another imaginary line 23.5°
south of the equator known as the Tropic of Capricorn.
The sun is directly over the Tropic of Cancer on the summer solstice and directly over the equator
and what's known as the equinoxes--it's directly over the other tropic on the winter solstice.
I'm using a northern hemisphere bias here.
If you're in the southern hemisphere, you'd probably refer to this as the winter solstice.
Now thinking that's what we did in Unit 1, let's say you're standing at some unknown latitude.
Where one where your latitude would just be this angle here which I've labeled α,
and let's say it happens to be one of the equinoxes
said the sun is directly above the equator and we do an experiment.
You look at a vertical object, measure its shadow, and do some trigonometry
to find that the angle here I've labeled α is equal to 40°.
So I want you to tell me for this measured angle of 40° and remember
this is when the sun is highest in the sky and the sun is directly overhead on the equator
so it's one of the equinoxes, what is your latitude.
Enter your answer in degrees here.